le but de l'aérodynamique c'est de
coller la voiture de coller mon pneu
encore plus fort par terre ça s'est
passé un jeu dernier coup sur coup deux
équipes d'étudiants de polytechnique
montréal ont remporté un premier prix
lors d'une prestigieuse compétition
d'ingénierie
[Musique]
un podium pour cette monoplace de course
qui a survécu à quatre jours d'épreuves
intensive un autre pour cette fusée qui
atteint 3500 mètres de hauteur et une
vitesse de ses 150 km heure dans les
deux cas on parle de véritable marathon
pour les participants ainsi le travail
que des étudiants font le soir après les
cours
entre les cours qu'on donne du temps
bénévole pour ça qu'on on prend des
vacances pour aller en compétition donc
c'est les centaines des milliers
d'heures investi par une quarantaine
d'étudiants sur des gros projets de même
des centaines d'universités participent
à ces compétitions très relevé qui
hausse la barre un peu plus haut chaque
année c'est pour ça qu'on fait
énormément de tester avant d'aller en
compétition on s'assure que toutes
pièces qui peut briser ou de tout ce qui
peut arriver sur l'auto on le fait
arriver avant d'être rendu là bas on
répare on retrouve des solutions à nos
problèmes
et après ce bain on peut performer
rendre fiable
les étudiants doivent construire le
prototype pièces par pièces en
améliorant les modèles des années
précédentes tout en renouvelant
constamment leur équipe
chaque année on recommence ce processus
donc en septembre on accueille les
nouveaux on leur apprend les bars
diffusent et puis c'est parti pour la
compétition et que j'avais en fait au
sein de ses équipes une rotation
d'environ un quart du personnel chaque
année et donc vous avez toute une
gestion de la connaissance acquise il
faut faire année après année et
transmettre finalement cette
connaissance aux générations suivantes
[Musique]
comme les compétitions sont organisées
par l'industrie du sport automobile et
de l'aérospatiale les meilleurs
étudiants sont rapidement repéré par les
professionnels la plupart des compagnies
sont leurs filets gagnants évidemment
équipes gagnantes sont sont visités par
par les compagnies pour pour recruter
donc si les belles opportunités pour les
membres de l'équipe qui est pour moi le
secteur de l'aérospatiale maintenant
dominées par le brie vie semble
particulièrement prometteur je pense
qu'une grande majorité d'entre nous
aimeraient ça travailler dans ce secteur
puis c'est ce que ça n'a pas été facile
dans le passé mais c'est vraiment un
domaine qui souffre puis c'est le bon
moment pour pour graduer dans ce domaine
sinon membres ont des radio canada
montréal